hi
and welcome to the sixth episode of the
weekly google cloud platform podcast
i'm francesca campoy and i'm here with
mark hey mark hey francesc how are you
doing
pretty good back to san francisco very
very excited to be back
we're in the same place at the same time
it's very exciting that's something new
yeah
so uh today we have a very exciting
uh episode we're gonna be talking with
ilya grigorik
yes uh very excited about this talking
about http 2 and http 2 on the google
cloud platform
hot topic yeah really good yeah that's
going to be really really interesting
there's a lot of
really interesting things not only about
http
2 but we're going to also be discussing
quick and like
cool things that people are trying to do
with http
i'm very excited about that yeah but
before that
we're going to be discussing about the
cool thing of the week uh
so what is the cool thing of the week oh
i like this uh i'll
i'm admittedly not a particular
minecraft user but i do love this whole
space i think it's really creative
uh a gentleman by the name of steve
slocum came up with
cubecraft which is which is a lovely way
to visualize what pods are running
inside your kubernetes cluster inside
minecraft it's well
well worth watching the video it's open
source code it's really cool
yeah i've seen the video too i think
it's really amazing
i'm really looking forward to more
people collaborating on that
because if you were able to include that
in kind of like a game where you could
actually be
killing killing host or killing pods and
seeing how they
get rescheduled somewhere else that
could be such an amazing thing yeah it
would be so much fun and then like you
kill one and it comes back up and you
kill one because i thought it would be
great i could really really like it yeah
but yeah so we will put the the link to
the video and the github repo
on the show notes that's for sure
wonderful well it sounds like then why
don't we get stuck into our interview
let's go for that brilliant so we are
joined today
by the wonderful and illustrious ilya
gregoric
thank you very much for joining us today
um did i manage to pronounce your name
right it's probably the first question i
need to ask
yes you did but wonderful and what was
the other one
illustrious yes i do like my adjectives
such a great word
says thank you so much for joining us
today we're we're we're very excited to
sit down and have a chat with you about
http 2
and how it affects google cloud platform
uh before we get into that why don't you
give us a bit of a you know background
on you and what you do
and sort of your position here at google
and all that sort of fun stuff
sure thing uh so first of all i guess
thank you for inviting me
uh to join you guys to talk about the
stuff this topic and
that's near and dear to my heart that
i've been working on for a while uh
speedy and hp2 in particular so
um i am a developer advocate uh also
within google i
sit not very far from you guys i can
probably wave at you
in the adjacent building and i work with
the
chrome team or have been working for a
while and also been working with the
make the walk fast team here at google
and our mission has always been to try
and figure out how to make the internet
faster as a whole
and of course make chrome faster and the
google products
and part of that was the speedy effort
that started back in
in around 2009 later graduated to http 2
and now we're doing exciting things with
quick
so lots lots of exciting things there
awesome well okay so you mentioned
three things there which is kind of fun
you mentioned speedy you mentioned
http 2 you mentioned quick why don't we
start with the first one
so what was speedy what what was that uh
and we could probably continue from
there sure
uh so when uh we started working on
chrome
within google one of the things that we
realized very early on
is that the current web pages that we're
building are
much more complicated than what the hp
protocol was originally designed for
right so the protocol that
the web is built on today was more or
less standardized 10 years ago
or even actually more so back in 1999
and since then we've started building
much
more complicated and interesting
applications we went from pages to
applications that fetch hundreds of
resources and all the rest
so when the effort to start working
chrome kicked off in around 2007 2008
we very quickly realized that first of
all speed is one of the tenets of chrome
we want to focus on speed and we
identified hp as one of the primary
bottlenecks
where just the number of connections
that you had to manage it's inefficient
both on the server and the client and we
were
really limited in the parallelism for
how many resources we could fetch uh
what kinds of signals we can communicate
to the server to help prioritize how the
data is
returned and all the rest so that was
the genesis of speedy
where we took a step back and just
looked at
what could we do to hcp to help reduce
or eliminate
some of the bottlenecks so the basic
insights were well if we add things like
framing such that we can split messages
instead of having one message occupy the
entire connection
which is how the hp one protocol works
where you send the request you have to
wait for the entire response before you
can send the next request
what if we could actually send multiple
multiple requests and responses over the
same connection
so that was framing then we looked at
well what about prioritization
so it turns out that modern applications
are both smart and complicated things
like as you start scrolling it would be
nice if we could
re-prioritize things like say an image
scrolls out of the viewport
it'd be nice to let the server know that
hey this is maybe not as important as it
was before because it's no longer
visible
or even simpler things like well i need
this javascript file before this image
file because
it's blocking rendering that's not
something you could actually express in
a protocol before so we started
looking at uh priorities and
then there's another feature with that
has to do with compression so we
realized that
the headers of http are always
transferred in plain sights they're not
compressed
hp allows the bodies to be compressed
but the like the get header is the user
agent string and all those things
are always transferred uncompressed and
frankly they're kind of redundant
oftentimes and there's a lot of that
data going back and forth
so we could if we could compress that
data that would
also speed up the protocol and then kind
of building on those primitives there's
additional things that went into the
protocols would just make it more
efficient and that was effective within
genesis of speedy
the chrome team implemented that or
started experimenting with it they
started
implementing it also on the server so
our google servers
and chrome were some of the first ones
to
kind of test this out and gather some
data from out in a while to see like
does
this
work and lo and behold it turns out that
it didn't work it
actually helped some of our services
quite a bit so
we took that proposal to ietf
and kind of started the discussion
around what could we do in the space
like speedy is just one
way of tackling this problem and after
some back and forth the ietf started a
new effort to
define http2 and they actually adopted
speedy
which at the time was draft two or
versions of the protocol as a starting
point
and then kind of the working group took
over and you know we continued to
contribute to it and work with the team
there and that effectively became hp2
nice so uh so what you're saying is that
uh at the beginning http 2 was basically
speedy
which was a google product but a good
project sorry
but uh from there it kept on evolving uh
to become a standard what are the main
differences between speedy and http 2
like what was added or removed from it
so
there's a lot of low level details like
though the framing is slightly different
like
if you care about how the bits are
aligned on the wire there's quite a few
subtle changes
we change the definition some of the
frames we change the part and how the
prioritization scheme works so for
example in speedy we had a fairly simple
model where you could just assign a
weight
in hp 2 it's it's much more
comprehensive it allows you to express
both weights and dependencies between
resources
we've done some additional work on
server push which is something we
actually haven't talked about but
in hp2 we have this new capability where
in response to a single request the
server can actually
push multiple responses back so a use
case here would be
hey you came and asked for the
index.html
but i know that you're going to ask for
the javascript file
and the style sheet right so why should
i wait for another round trip for you to
just come back to me and ask me for this
thing
so here just have it so that's that's
server push
uh and there's some other kind of
cleanups uh in all the rest that was
added
so the hp2 draft
or the kind of that work i think it went
through
i don't want to lie but it was
definitely more than a dozen iterations
and it was actually really really good
because
unlike a lot of the other protocols
this was being developed and tested in
the field so we
very early on of course we had chrome
support firefox also supported speedy
ie and safari also jumped on board so
while we were kind of testing hp2 we
were actually
like very very data driven so we had
these
uh meetings every three or four months
where we would come back and do interop
testing between all the browsers and the
major servers
of course there was google there was
twitter there was a facebook
and others that were experimenting with
the stuff so we could
make hypothesis right and say hey we
would like to propose this feature
instead of just arguing about it we
could actually try and implement it see
what the data says and then come back to
the drawing board and say what worked
and what didn't
so by the time the hp2 spec was actually
finalized and went out as a standard
we already had implementations in all
the browsers we had
very good implementations in many
servers including open source versions
so uh it was probably one of the best
tested protocols that we've
released in a long time um amongst all
the different stacks
okay so from the beginning we already
had support for
spb and http http2 on some google
services
and chrome and other people also jumped
into it
when did we start having that kind of
support in other google services like
especially google cloud platform
that's a good question i don't know the
exact date but i can say that
of course most if not all of our
services at google actually
are served by more or less the same
front-end which is our google front-end
or gfe
as we call it internally and a gfe was
where we've implemented spd support so
the support for speedy was effectively
enabled for
any and all google servers uh as long as
they use https this is actually one
thing we haven't talked about but in
order to use speed in http 2 you have to
use
https because the negotiation for the
protocol happens
when the tls handshake is done that's
how the client advertises that hey i
support hp2 and
the server picks that and
i believe actually that we had
kind of silent support for speedy for a
very long time especially in places like
app engine
where we actually haven't advertised it
much but we were certainly
like the first platform that supported
it so if you happen to have run your
your uh service on top of app engine
and with https you probably didn't even
know it
but you are already speed enabled which
is pretty cool so
one more reason to use https on top of
security is that it will be even faster
so okay so extending on from there it
leads us quite nicely into so
all right people are saying yep http 2
is awesome i want the extra speed you
know it's going to make my sights faster
how do i get http 2 now on like google
cloud platform what do i need to do to
get that enabled
right so actually i think that's that's
an even better question for me too
to phrase to you guys you know
probably even better than i do but um
depending i guess on how you set it up
uh you need to make sure that first of
all we said https
right that's kind of point one uh once
you have https you need to make sure
that whatever you're using
is able to negotiate http 2 on your
behalf
and then this question of how is that
routed to your back end so if you're
using something like a tcp load balancer
then you have to terminate
the https and have a server that is
capable of talking
http 2 whereas if you're using the like
https
load balancer which is hp aware uh then
it will do that work on your behalf
and i think we actually we have a pretty
nice
kind of diagram on our blog that that
shows all that
that that might have been a leading
question considering that you and i
worked on that plug together but that's
fine i'm happy with that
that's totally fine so yeah i mean it's
pretty cool like you put a load balancer
in front of it you go https you get
you know you get you know http 2 support
use app engine use https you get http 2
support
i i really like this i think it's
actually really really really powerful
yeah so actually this i think this
highlights something
very important so speedy and hp 2 does
not do not change anything
semantically about how hp works right
it's all the same methods it's all the
same headers it's all
it's all the rest so when i said earlier
that if you're running on https and an
app engine you're probably running
speedy
and you didn't even know it that's
actually that's very important
right so even today you're thinking like
so how do i enable hp2
it's like well switch over to hps
put a load balancer or a server that is
able to speak http 2
and your application will work there's
nothing extra that you need to do now
there are things that you could perhaps
do within your application to take
better advantage of some of the things
that hpc provides
but that's a whole different matter
no it's great that's great um so if they
want to take advantage we talked a
little bit about server push like
pushing up
assets are there any other things that
people might be able to take advantage
of they might want to
well i think this is where we get back
or get into
what kind of things you can do to get
the most out of hp2
right so hp2 removes
a lot of the bottlenecks that we
previously had to work around things
like concatenating files
and for the most part that was primarily
because the requests
having multiple independent requests was
just very costly from a latency
perspective
so we would take all of our like
beautiful modular javascript and css and
put it into one file and say here
here's a workaround right you just fetch
this one big blob of data
which is fine and like it works uh
except that it does run into issues with
things like caching so now
your designer comes along changes one
color and all of a sudden your entire
style sheet is invalidated
could you have split that such that you
know the the things that are changing
rapidly
are small such that next time it's
updated you just update that one file
that's fewer bytes for the client to
fetch when they come back to your site
it also means that the content is
fetched faster so it's like it's less
load it's faster load it's uh it's a win
all around right so now you can actually
start thinking about that and saying
well you know yeah i probably already
put in some like
automation in place that puts all the
files together into one bundle
maybe i want to undo all of that like i
probably don't want to ship hundreds of
files
because that has its own limitations
right but
like dozens is probably a very good kind
of safe spot
so that's that's that's one very
concrete example the other one is
server push as you mentioned so this is
actually something that developers have
been
sort of using unknowingly this is very
similar to inlining
so within lining it's kind of a similar
hack that says
well um maybe the request is so small
or i don't want you to come back so i'm
just going to embed it in another
resource like i'm going to take this
image and just basic c4 encoder and put
into html such that you don't have to
you don't even have to ask me for it but
that's what server
server push accomplishes as well except
server push when it's
when the resource is pushed uh actually
goes into the cache
so it's separate from an html file so
that resource can be reused across
multiple files it can be invalidated all
the same things
so that's another example and for server
push
i think we have some exciting news
coming up
maybe once this podcast goes live
that'll show you how to use that on on
app engine and other places as well so
i'm really excited about that that
sounds pretty exciting so
uh one of the things that i had to deal
before with and i didn't really enjoy
was the fact that
to serve better a bunch of images i had
to put them all in a single image and
then
do css tricks for that does that mean
that with http
that is not needed anymore right so
that's it's the exact same issue as
the javascript and css right we have a
lots we have lots of small icons
and it's just very expensive to fetch
them all because we have effectively
the maximum parallelism is six
connections or six requests
and my page has happens to have a
hundred icons right it's like that's
gonna take a long time
that's a lot of round trips so we put
them all into one file and then use the
css hacks
so yeah this is no longer necessary
because now the server or the client or
other can just send all hundred requests
over the single connection
and then the server can respond and
interleave that data as it wishes that
is really now as i said before
like if you're if you have thousands of
images
uh you know there are other concerns
where it may still be
useful to do some sort of spreading so
for example let's say all your icons are
kind of similar
you could actually get much better
compression if you put some of them
together
right like in terms of your actual image
format
so like there's some there's some
interesting areas to explore here it's
not just like unbundle everything
uh but at the same time i think that's
an exception
not the rule now whereas before like as
a rule we had to
put everything into one image file or
one css file or one javascript
and now that's more of an it's pattern
it kind of changes the rules of thumbs
that you would you would necessarily
like apply when you start building this
stuff
that makes a lot of sense yeah this
makes me think about the the demo
uh that we'll put on the show notes for
sure is this uh
http 2 demo developed by uh by
breakfast patrick from the go team so
basically
they show the difference between loading
i think it's around
like maybe 100 little images on hdb
one versus http 2 and it's quite amazing
like the difference is really nightmare
yeah and it's really important that like
as you look at those images you kind of
try and grok as to why that is
right and in hp1 world it's loading
slowly because you can we can fetch it
at most six tiles at a time and then
there's just many round trips to fetch
all the necessary tiles
and with ap http 2 the client just sends
all the requests at once so effectively
we're limited by the
speed of the link between the client and
the server cool
so so there's a lot of benefits from
moving from http1
to hp2 which actually came via first
that experiment that was
uh speedy what about quick you mentioned
that
what is sure so and actually before i go
to quick can i just
make one more uh note about about speedy
sure so of course of course
speedy evolved co-evolved with hp2
speedy was effectively the experimental
protocol
for hp2 so while we were working in hp 2
spec we were
testing things in speedy and some people
have
a good question of like so what does
that mean like do we keep speedy and do
we keep hp2
and the plan there is to deprecate pd so
we announced chrome announced that we
will deprecate speedy sometime in early
2016
because we want to encourage everybody
to shift over to hp2 and for example
when you look at support for http 2
across
nspd across some of the new browsers
like edge microsoft edge
they only support hp2 now so if you've
been running speedy
uh start looking at hp2 and the good
news is there's actually very good
server support now like nginx and apache
all have
uh support app engine of course and
all the like load balancers and all the
rest on
google cloud platform habits so just fyi
if you've been running speedy
look at http yeah that's a very
interesting point that's a fair point
yeah and then for quick
so that this is an interesting one uh
even when we started working on on
speedy we knew that
like the moment you address issues at
the hp layer you're going to run into
issues at the next layer down which is
tcp and tcp has some behaviors that
like head of line blocking that are not
optimal so for example if you have a
if you have packet loss if because tcp
guarantees inorder delivery if you
lose just one packet even though you may
have other packets already sitting in
your buffer you cannot deliver them
because you need to retransmit that
the first packet that was dropped such
that you can guarantee in order to
deliver
right yep so this seems like yeah so
what
uh but in practice that it can actually
be quite bad because if you think about
sending 100 like requests out
and then everything is stalled in that
one lost packet when you could have been
processing something else
that's suboptimal so just one example
other examples would be things like
mobility or mobile connections where
sometimes tcp or not sometimes
oftentimes actually
tcp gets misunderstands the behavior of
some of the mobile networks and
considers it to be like packet loss
where it's really not so it has some
optimal behaviors so looking at all that
we we kind of knew
that you know at some point we're going
to have to dig a little bit deeper
and try to change tcp or uh or
go some other route uh but when we
started working at speedy that was
frankly a bit too much to tackle at once
at both layers so we focused on the hp
layer
and then as that kind of migrated
towards
the itf working group and hp were kicked
off we started looking at
the next layer down so effectively quick
is
http 2 over udp
we have interesting yep
and you can imagine how that can be very
interesting complicated
so we've tried and we can
we do actually we have a a team within
google that works on tcp on linux kernel
and other things so we we've upstreamed
many improvements
over time but one thing we learned is
that tcp is actually very slow
in terms of the updates i cycle uh
getting support out in the client
rolling it out on the server and all the
rest
which is frankly for good reason right
because there's so much writing on it
that the last thing you want is crazy
experiments running out in the wild and
causing networks to collapse so uh the
people that maintained
all those all those branches and plus
you have all the hardware right
like big thin implementations of it that
you frankly can't even update at this
point
and udp offers a very simple interface
that provides
kind of no primitives whatsoever in
terms of reliability and all the rest
and that's something that we could
experiment with so we started with that
and we started effectively
re-implementing
uh some of the basic primitives of tcp
but also adding hooks
for new capabilities that we could
explore so things like plugable
congestion control
so maybe we can use different congestion
control strategy
for mobile networks or 2g networks
then uh when you're on google fiber and
you have like a gigabit link
right those are those have very very
different characteristics in terms of
how we should how we want to handle
congestion and other things
we also spent a lot of time looking at
eliminating latency during the handshake
so
we talked about requiring tls for hp2
it turns out that once you deploy http 2
because you don't need the extra
connections it actually mitigates a lot
of the latency cost of tls so
tls handshake itself adds two round
trips
of latency for the handshake if it's not
optimized
and if you're like if you've optimized
it well it's another round trip
which is still you know sometimes can be
significant
uh but that latency is offset based by
http 2
uh because it does not require as many
connections and you kind of amortize
that cost
over the lifetime of the connection with
kwik we
we actually wanted to get to a zero rtt
handshake
secure handshake where we can guarantee
that it's always encrypted
uh but we can send application data in
the first round trip so i can just start
talking to the server
and immediately send unencrypted data
such that there is no penalty cost
whatsoever for using encrypted sessions
so that was another big big change
and this work has been going on for a
while within chrome
uh it is i think we're on version 23 or
24
of quick protocol some of those changes
of course smaller than others but
uh it's actually i think it speaks
volumes that we're on
version 25 and in the meantime zero new
versions of tcp have shipped
right right so how much faster is
quick than like http 2 like obviously it
seems to be determined
on certain situations but like sort of
ball package
so it really depends it actually the
same question applies to http2 right
like how
how much faster is hp2 than http1 and
the answer there is it
really depends on your application it
depends on where your users are
based on the characteristics and all the
rest we do have some numbers that we've
shared for some of the google products
i think those this is data from maybe a
year or so ago
where we've seen improvements for
anywhere between 30 to 50 percent
in terms of latency overall latency for
our own products
now you know if all you do is you take
an hp 2 server
and like replace your current server
with an hp hp 2 server
i can't guarantee any sort of like oh it
will go two times faster right it really
depends on
how well your server is implemented and
how you're currently serving your
application like how many third parties
do you have
are you concatenating your files are
they unbundled and all the rest so
there's kind of a lot of gotchas in here
and then to answer your question on
quick um
when we compare it to hp2 once again
like it really depends
on the scenarios that we look at the
areas
where we found most success so far are
actually in
uh some of the developing markets like
india where we have very slow users with
very slow connections
and uh we've shared some numbers and i
can
give you guys the links to the to the
chromium blog that has
more details on this uh for example
youtube
saw a significant improvement in the
latency
like in reducing the number of rebuffers
and
improvements somewhere in the range of
like 20 to 30 percent again
for the latency of those users because
they were able to eliminate some of
those
retransmission delays and other things
so
you know there's no one number that i
can give you that it's like oh quick as
x percent faster no silver bullet
right no but at least that's very
interesting that uh
in the connections that are the slowest
that's where we're gonna get the
best improvement that's that's really
interesting well
yeah so at a very high level the
benefits that we're seeing
you can think of it as kind of a long
tail distribution right for a lot of the
connections in terms of latency and all
the rest
and what quick really helps us with at
least based on our current observations
is to rein in those tails and kind of
chop them off because we can
explicitly guard for those things and
implement smarter behaviors for very
slow networks so it allows us to be much
more like to
just eliminate a class of really bad
behaviors
which is actually very important for a
lot of people and for a lot of
applications
cool now that's good um so just to be
clear as well
so google is currently like
experimenting with like
quick on like the gfes and on google
cloud platform is that something that's
sort of being experimented on i'm
guessing it in chrome as well that's
right yeah so
the we have an implementation in in
chrome and if you're curious you can
actually
uh just pull up the chromium source and
and look at the
and look at the code there's a toy
server in there as well that i think was
just built for kind of small testing
and then our gfe again also implements
quick just as we did with speedy so
most of the speedy sorry most of the
google services are
already speaking quick um one thing that
you could do
and i recommend doing this is you can go
to the chrome
store and search for uh what's called i
think it's like the speedy
extension yeah the plugin that shows
this stuff yeah and
what it'll do is uh it'll show you like
a little lightning bolt
in your navigation bar uh it'll show
green when you're talking to a server
that's hp2
and it'll show red when it's talking to
a quick server and if you install that
and you start navigating to your
favorite google products you'll very
quickly find that you know it's showing
uh the red bullet quite often and that's
because uh most of our
services like youtube uh are already
being served over udp so
if you're watching this or some
something else on on youtube in chrome
chances are it's actually talking udp
today yep yeah i've got that installed
it's actually really fun to go around
the internet and i'm selling it right
now that sounds really interesting yeah
so speaking of not uh kind of
advertising this things too much uh i
think the same will happen
if you open your app engine app
and that that's running over https
you'll probably see a red bolt
which tells you that your application is
being served over quick
for the browsers that support it yes for
the browser to support it
yeah i think i i remember this and i
think i had to tweak a couple of things
inside chrome to get quick enabled ins
in the build that i was running a while
ago but
yeah okay i just drive with normal
normal chrome
uh our own page which is hosted by app
engine and i get hdb2
cool and we didn't do anything to get it
so that's nice that is nice yep
and so quick is already enabled by
default uh in chrome
we do run experiments we always have a
group
a random group that we hold back just
for a b testing and other things
so it may be the case that you know if
you try to open it and you don't see it
you may be
in that lucky group so you can force it
and you can override it if you go into
chrome settings
but just fyi wonderful all right well
before we finish up
uh is there anything else you want to
like mention
or plug or anything like that
uh well i guess a couple of things uh
first off uh
if you're running on app engine
definitely go and check out the blog
uh for that that covers hp2 and kind of
that whole
flow of which which service are you
using and how do you enable hp2
start with enabling https and make sure
that you have other things enabled
watch out for the server push support
i think that's coming soon it's actually
already there i think we just haven't
really talked about it
uh i think there's a theme here and then
finally there's
i think there's quick which lots of
people are really excited about so if
that's if protocols is
like something that you get excited
about then i definitely encourage you to
go read
the draft on atf uh give us feedback
install the extension play with it and
of course if you're running on app
engine then you know
poke around and see how it works under
the hood
wonderful all right well thank you very
much for joining us today ilya that was
very informative i really enjoyed it
thank you i really learned a lot today
awesome thank you guys so much thank you
thanks so much for joining us but we
have a wonderful question of the week
i've seen this come up a few times
people are looking at
different solutions for how do you do
like
long-running jobs like say video
transcoding uh
image processing maybe even code
compilation for build systems
and what options do they have available
to them to sort of do that sort of stuff
on google cloud platform but in a like a
cost efficient way like
there should be something there um yeah
so
i mean the obvious way to do it could be
of course you just have a machine that
it's running all the time but the
problem is that
maybe that's not the the most most cost
efficient way
so if you have something that you can
divide into small
chunks of work that you can retry if
something fails
then uh let's imagine that you put those
tasks in some
queueing system like pops up for
instance or absolutely
and then what you can do is have a
bunch of preemptible machines and
preemptible
vms basically what it means that those
machines
could be preempted or in other ways
you could be asked to stop using those
machines at some point
but uh you could if you can retry that
test later on
then that's not really a big issue and
now the cool thing is that
the cost is much much lower programmable
vms are up to 70 cheaper
yeah so that's that's a that's a huge
that's a good savings yeah that's a good
savings and it's pretty much a regular
machine
um they can last for up to 24 hours yeah
which is really cool but yeah if you
know they fall over and you're able to
just be like okay that's fine we'll just
try again for this thing
and anyway uh if you're writing anything
that is running on the cloud you should
always be
uh aware of the machine could fail at
any time so basically
most of the time you don't need to add
anything that you you could not have
been doing before yeah i can totally see
this make sense you know pubs up with a
preemptible vm pulling stuff off
yeah that makes that makes so much sense
and it could give you like some really
good savings
yeah and actually if some of you might
have heard about
this really cool thing that google
created uh mapreduce
which is just like a more sophisticated
way of doing exactly the same idea doing
just a bunch of
jobs that could fail and they will be
tried and so on but it's much more
complicated
running map reviews on preemptible vms
is a great match because mapreduce will
be managing the fact that if a
job fails it will be trailer on so you
don't need to add anything else
just say for instance maybe you will
have a an instant group
and in that instance template you will
say oh this vm should be preemptable
that's it just because you say that you
get a huge
uh huge saving you can do also really
cool stuff all our stuff is you know api
driven so if you want to spin these up
with apis and so you manage them
yourselves you can totally do that as
well i've seen people do it works really
really well
yeah yeah lots of cool things that you
can do with
uh with preventable vms uh lower
cost and still the same performance just
it might be preempted that's right
wonderful well francesc uh
where are you gonna be in the next
coming time you going anywhere it's
slowing down what's the end of year
well it's the end of the year so my next
trip is actually
holidays finally so lovely yeah
that's pretty much it after that i know
that late january
i will be going to foster uh
in brussels very nice yep i will be
in canada i'll be in vancouver uh
towards the end of
mid-december and the 12th for a dev fest
i'll be up there with
a couple of other of my colleagues but
yeah that's it for me
as well so it's sort of heading towards
the end of the year great
well thank you once again frances for
joining me for a wonderful episode of
our podcast it was a delight and a
pleasure to be here with you
as you say uh delight and a pleasure too
so talk to you all next week see you
next week